la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été distribuée nous
n'avons pas reçu d'observation
il y en a t-il en séance
je n'envoie point le procès-verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement je vous
rappelle que la séance est retransmise
en direct sur Public Sénat et sur notre
site internet au nom du bureau du sénage
rappelle à chacun le respect du temps de
parole et le respect des uns et des
autres je voudrais
saluer particulièrement un huissier
qui a servi le Sénat pendant 21 années
et qui a servi le Sénat pendant 34
années monsieur Auer je le cherche des
yeux le voilà il est ici et
ça me donne l'occasion de rendre de
saluer votre nom à tous tout le travail
que font les huissiers du Sénat à la
fois au service de la séance au service
du protocole et pour l'ensemble de notre
institution je voulais le souligner au
travers de l'exemple de Monsieur oway
avant de
passer la parole à notre collègue
président Pierre Laurent je sais dans
les secrets qu'il a décidé de ne pas
renouveler son mandat c'est sans doute
pas encore un secret d'État mais je
voudrais saluer celui qui est devenu
sénateur de Paris en 2012 son engagement
comme vice-président de notre commission
des affaires étrangères et depuis 3 ans
comme vice-président du Sénat chargé
notamment de l'ensemble de la vie
culturelle du palais et ce qu'on voit
autour du palais et au musée et à
l'Orangerie lui doit beaucoup je
voudrais le remercier pour aussi la
conduite sereine parfois il devait
bouillir en intérieur mais
de nos travaux dans cette émission et
c'est attaché à le préserver en toute
circonstances mais maintenant je lui
donne la parole comme
vice-président membre du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre
après le drame survenu hier à Nanterre
l'émotion est très vive dans le pays
j'ai mal à ma France à titré à tweeté
Killian Mbappé disant avec ces mots ce
que ressentent je crois des millions de
jeunes et de parents choqués par la
vidéo du drame on y voit un policier
braquer son arme à bout portant par la
portière du véhicule et tiré
mortellement sur le conducteur un jeune
de 17 ans je pense que cette émotion est
également présente dans les
commissariats de France dans lesquels
beaucoup de fonctionnaires ont ce matin
mal à leur métier
je veux y joindre ici l'émotion de tout
mon groupe devant la douleur de la
famille on ne peut pas mourir à 17 ans
pour un refus d'obtempérer
jeudi ma solidarité à la famille du
jeune Naël je dis également mon soutien
entier au maire de Nanterre Patrick
Jarry et aux élus de cette grande ville
populaire qui vole la vérité la vidéo du
contrôle et du tir et glaçante le
policier a été placé en garde à vue et
mis en examen pour homicide volontaire
par personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique c'est dire la gravité des
fesses soumis désormais en quête la
lumière madame la Première ministre doit
être faite dans les meilleurs délais car
ce que nous avons vu est parfaitement
révoltant
l'IGPN doit à la famille la plus grande
transparence et la vérité une enquête
enterrée de plus ne sera pas accepté par
les n'ont rien
au-delà de l'enquête qui doit donc
suivre son cours avec rapidité est-il
envisagé madame la Première ministre de
afin de réagir à la mesure des faits
incriminés de prononcer une suspension à
titre conservatoire de l'agent concerné
j'ajoute que la mort de ce jeune homme
n'est malheureusement pas un cas isolé
il y a eu un doublement des nombres de
morts dans ces circonstances depuis 2017
ne serait-il pas tant d'engager la
révision de la doctrine
utilisée dans ces cas-là qui a conduit à
la brutale accélération de ces drames
mortels madame la Première ministre un
pays dans lequel la police et la
jeunesse ne peuvent pas se croiser sans
inquiétude et angoisse est un pays
malade de sa démocratie c'est votre
responsabilité de changer au plus vite
ce climat
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre madame la
Première ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Pierre
Laurent
hier à Nanterre lors d'un contrôle
routier un jeune homme de 17 ans a été
tué c'est un terrible drame et je veux
commencer par dire ma profonde émotion
et adresser mes condoléances à sa
famille à ses proches et à son quartier
le président de la République a eu
l'occasion de le dire ce matin c'est la
Nation toute entière qui est touchée par
ce drame
je me suis entretenu tout à l'heure avec
le maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
lui ai dit mon soutien celui de mon
gouvernement et j'ai partagé avec lui
notre détermination à ce que toute la
vérité soit faite
aujourd'hui il y a un choc un deuil une
colère c'est à la justice d'y répondre
je connais l'engagement de nos policiers
et de nos gendarmes au quotidien sur le
terrain ils savent que porter l'uniforme
c'est répondre à un devoir celui de
l'exemplarité les images choquantes
diffusées hier montre une intervention
qui ne semble manifestement pas conforme
aux règles d'engagement de nos forces de
l'ordre la justice devra établir les
faits elle a été saisie elle a commencé
son travail un policier est en garde à
vue et je souhaite comme chacun que la
vérité soit faite le plus rapidement
possible et que des réponses soient
apportées la justice passera personne ne
doit en douter
seul la justice permettra de faire toute
la lumière sur ce drame
seule la justice apportera des réponses
face à la douleur d'une famille et à la
peine d'une nation seule la justice
garantira notre unité et alors que des
violences ont éclaté cette nuit dans
certains quartiers tout particulièrement
dans les Hauts-de-Seine je veux appeler
chacun à l'apaisement
monsieur le sénateur Pierre Laurent nous
voulons la justice pour Naël et nous
l'obtiendrons mais elle doit être rendue
de manière pacifique ces mots sont ceux
du maire de Nanterre Patrick Jarry je
veux les saluer et avec vous aujourd'hui
je m'y associe je vous remercie
la parole est notre collègue Patricia
Sillinger pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail monsieur le
ministre permettez-moi d'associer à
cette question mon collègue Ludovic est
dans deux jours seulement les
dérogations qui permettent de
travailleurs frontaliers qui exercent en
Suisse de télétravailler s'achèveront en
réaction à la crise sanitaire la France
et la Suisse ont en effet levé les
restrictions fiscales et sociales qui
freinaient jusque là le recours au
télétravail par les travailleurs
concernés or cette organisation a
largement contribué à l'amélioration de
la qualité de vie de ces travailleurs et
fait particulièrement sens au moment où
l'urgence climatique exige de limiter
notre consommation d'énergie fossiles
j'ai donc à de nombreuses reprises
attirer l'attention du gouvernement j'ai
milité pour une solution pérenne et
favorable télétravail des frontal
aujourd'hui ces derniers sont inquiets
et craignent qu'au-delà du 30 juin leur
capacité à télétravailler soit nouveau
limitée en décembre dernier un accord
fiscal a été conclu leur permettant de
télétravailler jusqu'à 40 % de leur
temps de travail sans modification des
règles d'imposition sur le revenu je
note cependant qu'une incertitude
demeure quant au cas des missions
temporaires effectuées hors de Suisse
sur le plan social un accord
multilatéral en discussion permettrait
de déroger à la limite des 25%
autorisant jusqu'à 49% de télétravail
c'est un signal prometteur pour des
milliers de frontaliers pour autant la
France n'a toujours pas fait part de ses
attentes quant à sa volonté de rejoindre
ou non cet accord en conséquence
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous nous
dire quelles sont les intentions de la
France quant à la signature de cet
accord
et plus largement pourriez-vous rassurer
nos concitoyens sur l'évolution des
règles de télétravail applicables à
partir du 30 juin 2023 merci pour vous
répondre la parole est communiste du
travail le plein emploi monsieur du stop
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice finoger je sais votre
implication sur la question des
travailleurs frontaliers et vous savez
aussi qu'avant la crise covid en
application du règlement 883 relatif à
la coordination des règlements de
sécurité sociale des pays de des pays de
l'Union européenne et de la Suisse
s'appliquer la règle suivante le
télétravail était limité à un jour par
semaine pour les travailleurs
frontaliers et les travailleurs
frontaliers qui travaillaient plus d'un
jour par semaine en télétravail basculer
dans leur région social de leur État de
résidence plutôt qu'être maintenu dans
le régime social de leur état employeur
avec la crise covid des souplesse sont
évidemment été apportées en matière
fiscale et en matière sociale et nous
avons prolongé ces accords des
rogatoires jusqu'au 30 juin 2022 en 2022
un groupe de travail a été mis en place
pour rédiger un accord multilatéral et
ce groupe avait recommandé que la
période de souplesse va prolongée
jusqu'au 30 juin 2023 dans maintenant
quelques jours l'accord multilatérale a
été rédigé la France l'examine avec
attention
avec attention et avec un regret le
regret que les règles en matière
d'assurance chômage n'est pas été
intégré dans cet accord multilatéral
relatif au télétravail c'est d'ailleurs
un regret qui fait quoi d'autre
discussions puisque le règlement 883-2
coordination des règlements de sécurité
sociale au niveau européen que j'ai
évoqué fait l'objet aujourd'hui d'une
tentative de révision et sur les
différents chapitres qui font cet accord
le chapitre de l'assurance chômage et
notamment de l'exportation des droits en
matière d'assurance chômage pour les
travailleurs frontaliers reste un
chapitre en débat nous regardons ce
qu'avec attention évidemment avec la
volonté de faire valoir les intérêts de
la France et de notre système de
protection sociale nous le faisons avec
Madame le Premier ministre en entendant
aussi le besoin de sécurisation et
d'accompagnement de nouvelles modalités
de travail que connaissent aujourd'hui
les frontaliers qui comme l'ensemble des
salariés connaissent un développement du
télétravail plus important que ça n'a
jamais été le cas d'ici au 30 juin donc
dans quelques heures maintenant les
décisions seront rendues publiques avec
ce double objectif accompagner nos
frontaliers et dans le même temps faire
valoir les intérêts de notre pays
merci la parole est au président Patrick
Kanner pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre
hier matin à Nanterre Naël 17 ans a été
tué à bout portant par un membre des
forces de l'ordre
nous ne connaissons pas encore les
circonstances exactes de ce drame mais
les images sont terribles la lumière
doit être faites car un refus
d'obtempérer ne peut ne doit se terminer
par la mort d'un jeune
nos premiers mots vont naturellement à
la famille de la victime et à sa maman
toute mort et tragique mais quand la
victime a 17 ans et que les
circonstances sont celles que l'on
connaît on peine à imaginer la
souffrance des proches le temps du deuil
doit être respecté
aussi les violences et dégradations
qu'on en a pu constater hier Nanterre et
dans d'autres villes françaises doivent
être condamnés elles le seront jamais la
solution il nous joignons aux demandes
de Patrick Jarry maire de Nanterre nous
voulons comprendre et nous appelons à la
retenue les enquêtes administratives et
judiciaires doivent aboutir vite à la
manifestation de la vérité conditions du
retour au calme mais ce n'est pas
suffisant
dans le tel circonstances chacun doit
être à la hauteur de ses responsabilités
je dénonce les tweets incendiaires de
certains syndicats de policiers
minoritaires certes mais néanmoins
intolérable vous l'entendrez jamais de
surenchir dans nos paroles madame
famille ministre nous croyons à la
police de la République mais lorsqu'un
drame comme celui d'hier se produit
c'est l'exemplarité de l'État de droit
qui est interrogé et c'est aussi son
autorité qui est potentiellement
fragilisée en conséquence il faut
objectivement évaluer l'application de
l'article 435-1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure sur l'usage des armes et en
tirer les conséquences il faut également
reconsidérer la formation des policiers
et les moyens qui y sont alloués tout au
long de leur carrière avec cette
tragédie au-delà des paroles vos
réponses et vos actes doivent participer
à l'apaisement que le pays attend madame
la Première ministre il y a urgence
pour vous répondre la parole des keV
Adam la première minute
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Patrick
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire la mort
d'un adolescent de 17 ans est un drame
épouvantable le président de la
République a dit tout à l'heure la peine
et l'émotion de la nation à mon tour à
nouveau avec tout mon gouvernement je
veux adresser mes condoléances à la
famille et au proche de Naël et leur
dire toute ma solidarité la justice est
saisie elle avance l'auteur du coup de
feu est en garde à vue et je souhaite
comme chacun que la vérité puisse être
faite au plus vite alors vous
m'interrogez spécifiquement sur nos
règles et sur la formation de nos forces
de l'ordre
vous connaissez tout comme moi monsieur
le Président canner leur engagement au
quotidien
policier et gendarmes connaissent leurs
devoirs d'exemplarité et comme nous
l'avons toujours dit quand il y a des
fautes les fonctionnaires ont à en
répondre tant au plan administratif que
judiciaire
les images particulièrement choquantes
du contrôle de Naël donne ta pensée que
le cadre d'intervention légale n'a pas
été respectée mais seul la justice le
dira et nous en tirons évidemment toutes
les conséquences et dans l'immédiat le
ministre de l'Intérieur prendra les
décisions qui s'imposent à l'issue de la
garde à vue
monsieur le Président canner le retour
deuil à l'enquête et à l'apaisement nous
avons une exigence absolue de vérité
c'est elle qui nous permettra de
surmonter les colères et de donner les
réponses qu'attendent légitimement la
famille de Naël les élus et les Français
je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes monsieur le président
merci président pour votre générosité
madame la Premier ministre beaucoup
d'entre nous sont d'anciens élus
responsables des lunes nationaux et nous
avons même été parfois ministre en
charge des politiques de la ville et
nous savons que la vérité et la justice
sont l'outil du meilleur apaisement dans
nos quartiers merci pour votre
mobilisation mais nous attendons
beaucoup de vos actes dans la matière
la parole est-elle notre collègue
Christian BIAC pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci et monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre mesdames les ministres
monsieur les ministres ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur mitre
en France et le pouvoir d'achat des
Français en est fortement impacté même
chez le recul le retour à un niveau de
prix d'avoir une guerre en ukraine-loire
donc compatriotes sont confrontés à une
forte hausse des prix dans des secteurs
de première nécessité et la précarité
alimentaire restale comme en témoigne
les associations d'aide d'urgence qui
ont accueilli 22% de bénéficiaires en
plus depuis un an
parallèlement à l'heure de la
réindustrialisation de la France toutes
les entreprises ont des difficultés pour
recruter et il a de même dans le
chercheur public dans l'éducation
nationale dans la justice dans les
hôpitaux dans l'armée dans la police ou
la gendarmerie et dans les collectivités
territoriales les candidatures ne sont
pas assez nombreuses et les postes
ouverts au concours de son pas pourvu en
réponse le gouvernement a privilégié la
politique du chèque de la prime ou
encore du bouquet tarifaire les salariés
ne veulent pas de chaque distribuer
comme une au monde ou encore comme la
pièce que me donner ma grand-mère quand
j'étais petit le samedi ils veulent tout
simplement un salaire leur permettant de
vivre correctement
la politique des primes entre chaque
pouvait se comprendre durant la crise
sanitaire mais cette réponse est
désormais adaptée si cela donne un coup
de pouce momentané au pouvoir d'achat le
fait de notre pas sujet au cotisations
sociales fera que les travailleurs
pauvres d'aujourd'hui seront des
retraités très pauvres de demain c'est
pourquoi je vous demande si vous
envisagé d'index chez les salaires sur
les prix afin que la perte de pouvoir
d'achat des salariés et de retraités ne
continuent pas de s'aggraver
pour vous répondre la parole est la
madame la ministre déléguée en charge
des petits du moyen-entreprise du
commerce madame Olivia Grégoire vous
avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur Billac
le gouvernement depuis maintenant deux
ans est aux côtés
des concitoyens français des salariés et
les soutiens pas uniquement avec des
chèques pour me référer très précisément
à votre question mais aussi avec des
mesures importantes comme le bouclier
tarifaire vous l'avez mentionné mais
aussi depuis six mois désormais avec
Bruno Le Maire avec Roland Lescure en
incitant sans faire de chèques à la fois
les acteurs de la grande distribution
mais aussi les acteurs des de
l'industrie agroalimentaire à renégocier
à baisser les prix la réalité c'est que
les prix sont en train de baisser vous
l'avez mentionné je rappelle quand même
que pour la première fois depuis
septembre 2021 l'inflation alimentaire a
baissé nous étions à 14.9 en mai
alors que nous étions à 15.8 en avril
les baisses de prix sont en train d'être
discutées vous parlez de produits de
première nécessité des renégociations
sont en cours en ce moment même nous
l'avons demandé avec Bruno Le Maire au
75 plus gros industriels de
l'agroalimentaire dès le premier juillet
très concrètement dans les rayons des
grandes surfaces notamment un certain
nombre de produits vont baisser
visiblement je pense à l'huile de
tournesol je pense aux pattes mais je
pense aussi par exemple à la volaille je
pense aussi à un certain nombre de
produits de snacking je pense au
vinaigre je pense au thé je ne vais pas
vous faire toute la logorrhée mais les
prix sont en train de baisser certains
continuent à augmenter il faut être très
lucide certains cours de matières
premières continuent à être élevés je
pense au sucre je pense au porc je pense
à la charcuterie donc il y aura des
baisses de prix et d'autres prix qui ne
baisseront pas immédiatement pour ce qui
est de votre suggestion d'indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation
il y a un pays voisin qui l'a fait c'est
la Belgique
ce pays a des taux d'inflation
extrêmement élevés ce pays voit des
salariés qui se battent pour aussi payer
leurs courses mais surtout qui sont
battus tout l'hiver pour payer leurs
factures d'électricité ça n'est
malheureusement pas la solution possible
dans tous les pays ça n'est pas la
solution que nous avons choisie elle
n'est pas à notre sens la plus efficace
pour les protéger merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur
je suis heureux d'apprendre que les prix
n'augmentent plus c'est parce que disent
les gens que je rencontre c'est pas ce
que je constate quand je vais faire mes
courses et puis je crois que il faut
quand même arrêter de montrer du doigt
les salariés les gens qui se lèvent le
matin pour travailler on leur a mis deux
ans de retraite de plus hier encore les
montrer du doigt pour les arrêts de
travail mais quand il fait ces gens qui
se lèvent le matin pour travailler je me
demande
merci
la parole est votre collecte Thomas
dessus pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur un
jeune homme de 17 ans est mort hier
Naël a été abattu par un agent de police
à bout portant aujourd'hui au nom du
groupe écologiste j'adresse penser et
condoléances à sa mère sa famille et ses
amis aujourd'hui après une nuit de
colère dans certaines villes
d'Île-de-France notre rôle doit être
d'appeler au calme au nom du respect
pour le temps du recueillement à la
mémoire de Naël au nom du respect de la
justice et de la vérité ce matin face
aux images le président de la République
a parlé d'un acte inexcusable et
inexplicable inexcusable sans aucun
doute inexplicable certainement pas oui
il y a des raisons qui ont conduit à ce
drame nous nous souvenons ici des
efforts que vous avez déployés monsieur
le ministre pour combattre dans cette
hémicycle toutes les propositions visant
à améliorer les rapports entre la police
et la population fidèle à votre doctrine
100% répressive nous nous souvenons
votre acharnement à vouloir interdire
de filmer l'action de la police et nous
voyons comment depuis des années drame
après drame avec détermination vous
défendez la honteuse loi Cazeneuve qui
permet à la police d'ouvrir le feu sur
les chauffeurs d'une voiture selon des
conditions manifestement trop floues
depuis cette loi 40% des tirs sur des
véhicules en plus par rapport aux 5
années la précédente l'an dernier 13
décès ont été enregistrés après des
refus donc tempérés lors des contrôles
routiers un record un triste record
cette loi est manifestement trop laxiste
elle a manifestement permis le
développement d'un sentiment d'impunité
qui hier a conduit à un drame monsieur
le ministre si vous voulez que le calme
revienne et nous l’appelons de nos vœux
il est temps de revenir sur cette loi
combien de morts supplémentaires
faudra-t-il pour que vous en preniez
conscience
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
j'ai eu l'occasion
comme l'a fait à l'instant madame la
Première ministre comme l'a fait
président de la République de dire
évidemment tout le drame que nous
inspire ce qui s'est passé hier à
Nanterre que la justice doit très vite
apporter des réponses et que des
sanctions seront prises contre un
policier qui manifestement d'après les
images extrêmement choquantes que nous
avons vu et bien sûr des premiers
éléments de l'enquête qui ont qui sont
sortis de la presse manifestement pas
été conforme monsieur le sénateur à la
législation et à la déontologie à la
formation de la police nationale mais je
crois monsieur qu'en toute chose en tout
temps il faut avoir de la dignité je
crois que la récupération politique au
moment où une famille pleure son enfant
au moment où des écoles ont été
attaquées hier au moment au 24 policiers
ont été blessés ont partout en France il
peut y avoir une légitime émotion et un
énervement qui évidemment ne peut être
accepté sont les règles de la République
il ne peut pas y avoir de récupération
politique
vous avez monsieur sénateur fait un
drôle de parallèle celui désormais de
vouloir que nous légiférons sous
l'émotion finalement et vous avez
monsieur le sénateur profité c'est
affreux de ce terrible drame pour
rappeler votre opposition à la loi qui
avait prise de président Hollande et le
Premier ministre Cazeneuve dans des
temps différents puisque c'était des
temps je le rappelle d'attentat
terroriste qui prévoit dans l'article
que vous évoquez non pas que des
policiers ou des gendarmes puissent
tirer sur une voiture c'est totalement
faux et c'est fou de le dire dans cette
hémicycle aux yeux des Français monsieur
sénateur fait que dans certaines
circonstances lorsque les policiers sont
eux-mêmes en danger de mort qu'ils
puissent utiliser leur arme est-ce que
ce policier était en danger de mort pour
utiliser son arme c'est ce que montrera
l'enquête judiciaire a priori des images
que l'on a tous vu de son choquantes
parce que ça ne correspond pas à la loi
2017 loi 2017 que je ne veux pas ici
particulièrement justifié devant vous
n'ayant pas été son auteur mais surtout
trouvant que c'est le temps du deuil du
recueillement et la dignité républicaine
et non de la récupération politique
merci
[Applaudissements]
Monsieur Thomas dessus
monsieur le ministre il n'y aura pas de
paix sans vérité il n'y aura pas de
justice en vérité et la vérité c'est que
vous continuez de soutenir cette loi
c'est toi qui a conduit à ce drame
la vérité c'est que cette loi va en
provoquer d'autres je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Dany
boitemblade pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoire
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le sport doit toujours
contribuer à la cohésion de notre
société il permet à chacun et à chacune
de se réaliser dans l'effort quel que
soit son origine et sa culture sociale
j'ai toujours défendu cette valeur une
universaliste du support hier comme
local aujourd'hui comme sénateur nous
sommes nombreux ici à rester fidèles à
l'esprit de Pierre de Coubertin à moins
d'un an des Jeux olympiques de Paris il
me paraît essentiel de rappeler le
caractère universel des valeurs du sport
car elles sont de plus en plus
contestées dans notre pays
le collectif DJ abuzz revendique ainsi
le droit de participer à des
compétitions officielles de football en
portant le foulard islamique alors qu'en
Iran des femmes risquent leur vie pour
vivre sans le voile en France certaines
se battent pour pouvoir l'imposer sur
les terrains de football
ont attaqué l'article premier des
statuts de la fédération française de
football qui interdit tout port de
signes ou tenues manifestement au
sentiment une appartenance politique
philosophique religieuse ou syndicale
lundi il aura peut-être un public de
table a donné un avis favorable à leur
revendication plutôt que permettre une
revendication religieuse sur un terrain
de football il est essentiel de
préserver le sport de tous séparatisme
c'est le sens d'approvision de la loi
que j'ai faite le 25 mai du 22 soyons
lucides les islamiques s'engouv dans
toutes les portes ouvertes et le sport
en Neptune madame la ministre je ne vous
demande pas de commenter une décision de
cash-6 n'a pas encore rendu cependant le
gouvernement est-il prêt à légiférer
pour clarifier notre droit si nécessaire
et garantir dans notre religieuse dans
le sport
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre des Sports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame ou
déjà Castéra vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur va te blettes je vous remercie
de ne pas me demander de commenter une
affaire juridictionnelle qui est en
délibérée les séances d'État travaillait
jusqu'au bout dans le respect de son
impartialité de son indépendance et ce
d'autant que je le rappelle que la
formation de jugement n'est pas tenue
par les conclusions du rapporteur public
cette décision elle sera rendue demain
on va en analyser le sens la portée les
justifications et voir si nécessaire
s'il y a besoin de prendre une
initiative politique si oui de quel type
et avec quel support dans cette attente
ce que je veux faire c'est rappeler
notre double boussole la défense de
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et la préservation de la laïcité dans le
sport ce qui veut dire un assurer la
neutralité du service public y compris
au cœur de nos équipes de France deux
préserver la liberté de conscience qui
est une liberté de croire et de ne pas
croire et donc la quantité 3 de lutter
fermement contre toutes les formes de
séparatisme et de prosélytisme dans le
sport pour ça on a un outil le contrat
d'engagement républicain pour ça nous
renforçons nos moyens d'intervention
d'enquêtes pour ça nous diligentons des
contrôles 3500 déjà sur l'année 2022
pour ça nous accompagnons les éducateurs
les formateurs les fédérations pour que
les signalements puissent remonter plus
vite et que notre combat soit plus
efficace que jamais contre toutes ces
formes de dérive inacceptables vous le
voyez nous sommes aux côtés des clubs du
mouvement sportif pour faire respecter
notre modèle républicain notre modèle
sportif et lutter contre toutes celles
et ceux qui voudraient y porter atteinte
préserver ce pacte républicain au cœur
du sport voilà notre détermination la
plus absolue
à légiférer contre ces signes religieux
dans le sport et garder le principe de
laïcité
pour vous répondre pardon je donne la
parole à notre collègue Michel Savin
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre le ce lundi le rapporteur
public du Conseil d'État s'est prononcé
donc pour l'annulation de l'article
premier des statues de la Fédération
française de football qui interdit tout
port de signe religieux lors des
compétitions sportives à la suite d'un
recours porté par les jabuses et
l'Alliance citoyenne un collectif qui
instrumentalise régulièrement nos
institutions et nos principes
républicains sans préjugés de la vie du
Conseil d'État nous tenions à vous faire
part de notre vie inquiétude quant à
cette attaque du pack républicain mais
aujourd'hui nous n'en serions pas là si
votre gouvernement ne s'était pas opposé
à notre proposition d'interdiction du
port de si nous religieux lors des
compétitions sportives organisées par
les fédérations sportives et les
associations affiliées à plusieurs
reprises notre majorité a adopté cette
proposition en 2020 en 2021 comme en
2022 pendant l'examen des textes
confortant les valeurs de la République
au sud ou celui visant à démocratiser le
sport en France à chaque fois votre
gouvernement votre majorité l'ont rejeté
par ce refus de soutenir notre
initiative vous avez ouvert la porte à
ses dérives communautaires madame la
ministre assumez-vous cette faute
politique et êtes-vous favorable à
mettre en débat et soutenir la
proposition de loi sur ce sujet que nous
avons redéposé en début d'année par
ailleurs quelle action madame Élise
comptez-vous avoir vis-à-vis de ses
associations qui compromettent notre
pack crépublicain
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame la Ministre des Sports
vous avez la parole
monsieur le sénateur mesdames monsieur
le Président pardon mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Savin je voudrais évidemment un
nouveau rappeler le principe le respect
du pardon Michel est là à la séparation
des pouvoirs que je viens d'évoquer
compte tenu de la faire juridictionnelle
qui est en délibéré moi ce que je veux
vous dire c'est notre détermination avec
la première ministre avec l'ensemble de
ce gouvernement de lutter pour préserver
la laïcité dans le sport comme elle l'a
rappelé hier nous sommes et resterons
intransigeants sur le respect de la
neutralité du service public dans le
sport jusqu'au cœur de nos équipes de
France nous serons intransigeants sur la
lutte contre toutes les formes de
prosélytisme et de radicalisme nous
serons également déterminés en faveur de
la défense de l'égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes je crois que sur tous ces
points monsieur le sénateur nous
regardons dans la même direction la
question que vous posez elle est
légitime mais permettez-moi de vous dire
qu'elle est prématurée nous allons
regarder cette décision nous allons
l'analyser regarder les considérants les
motivations et toutes les conclusions
que nous devons en tirer sans rien
exclure vous rappelez les initiatives
que vous avez portées par le passé nous
avons évidemment étudié avec attention
mais je veux rappeler qu'elle n'était
pas toujours présentée sur le bon
support juridique et d'autre part
qu'elle n'était pas toujours entourées
de toutes les garanties rendu nécessaire
par le respect de notre Constitution la
laïcité est au cœur du pacte républicain
il faut donc un socle républicain pour
la soirée elle aussi on va donc regarder
jusqu'au bout cette décision et
identifier les espaces qu'elle rend
nécessaire ou non pour l'action
politique et avec quels instruments ce
contexte j'en suis convaincu est une
opportunité pour clarifier pour
réaffirmer notre cadre d'action avec les
bons éclairages juridiques autour de
nous et pour préserver jusqu'au bout la
laïcité dans le sport et donner aux
fédérations le contexte clair et le plus
homogène possible qu'elles attendent
nous le leur devons et elles le
souhaitent monsieur le sénateur je ne
laisserai aucune dérive entachée notre
sport et je sais pouvoir agir en ce sens
avec vous ainsi qu'avec tous les
parlementaires qui sont attachés au
pacte républicain je vous remercie
monsieur ça va
madame la ministre stop stop à
l'hypocrisie au manque de courage
politique de ce gouvernement et face à
la radicalisation de certaines
organisations et la multiplication de
ces dérives religieuses si le Conseil
d'État suit la vie du rapporteur public
ne soyons pas naïf cela se traduira par
une victoire pour celle qui souhaite
fragiliser avec cette offensive
religieuse un des piliers de notre
société et se traduira par la même par
une défaite politique pour notre
République la réponse du gouvernement ne
peut pas se limiter à des contrôles ou à
des signatures de partenariat avec les
fédérations les toits doivent mettre fin
à cette spirale communautaire qui est à
l'opposé des valeurs du sport et de la
République madame la ministre soutenez
notre proposition de loi
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Christine
Herzog pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
pour aller plus fort
monsieur le Président Madame la première
ministre mes chers collègues j'associe à
ma question ma collègue Sylvie
vermeiller sénatrice du Jura en 2018 la
SNCF a suspendu la liaison directe Metz
Nancy Lyon en raison des travaux
réalisés à Lyon Part-Dieu qui empêchait
son maintien ses travaux devaient durer
quatre ans quatre ans pendant lesquels
la patience des usagers de ce TGV a été
mise à rude épreuve à l'issue des
travaux de la SNCF s'étaient engagé à
repositionner la desserte qui du
Luxembourg à Vintimille permettait aux
usagers de gagner en temps et en
changement
c'était un réel atout pour les quatre
régions des services du Grand Est à la
PACA en passant par la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté et l'Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
or la SNCF vient de faire savoir qu'elle
annulait finalement cette desserte pour
la renvoyer par tronçon au conseiller
régionaux concerné
à côté de cela elle conseille aux
usagers d'utiliser le TGV Metz
Strasbourg Colmar Dijon celui-là même
qui cible bien plus la clientèle
frontalière que la population française
due au centre des régions or le
contribuable qui soit alsacien ou
Laurent à autant financer la SNCF et
mérite un accès égal au service public
il apparaissent scandaleux que
l'actionnaire majoritaire l'État se
laisse dicter les lois du marché
lucratif de sorte à abandonner le
service public et une ligne française
historique dans le même temps l'État et
ses contribuables prennent en charge 35
milliards d'euros de SNCF réseau pour
éponger sa dette
madame la Première ministre comment
pouvez-vous le 24 février dernier
annoncé un grand plan d'investissement
de 100 milliards d'euros à horizon 2040
pour le secteur ferroviaire et 4 mois
plus tard accepter la suppression de
cette ligne indispensable au maillage de
notre territoire je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame
la sénatrice Christina
de vous répondre s'il avait été présent
dans cette émission puisque vous savez
l'attention particulière qu'il porte à
ce sujet en quelques mots vous avez
rappelé le cadre ces travaux à Lyon
Part-Dieu 4 ans d'interruption et au
moment où la reprise aurait pu s'amorcer
la prise de position de la SNCF disons
que le trafic
escompté ne justifie pas d'y affecter
les matériels qui auparavant
permettaient d'assurer cette desserte
le gouvernement est pas resté inactif le
ministre délégué chargé des Transports a
pris des engagements précis pour que
cette liaisonaisse Lyon qui passe par
Nancy puisse réouvrir il y avait qu'à la
minute où nous nous parlons à la fois
des interrogations sur la cadence et sur
le niveau de service qui ont suscité la
mobilisation des élus de ce territoire
au cours de ces dernières mois et je
sais la sensibilité et la mobilisation
particulière madame la sénatrice herzogh
dont vous avez fait preuve la préfète de
la région Grand Est a réuni la SNCF les
services de l'État les élus les
parlementaires intéressés dont vous et
elle le refera à nouveau pour préciser à
la suite des réunions précédentes la
faisabilité technique de ce qui a été
évoqué vous savez que nous discutons de
l'usage temporaire de TER qui soit issus
de la région Grand Est mais il y a
derrière la question au-delà de ce
temps-là du type de matériel qui
pourrait être affecté et de la date de
livraison de train d'équilibre
territoriaux qui ont été esquissés
il y a des sujets budgétaires il y a des
sujets techniques je termine sur un mot
puisque encore une fois cette réunion
est censée se tenir dans les toutes
prochaines semaines le plan annoncé par
la première ministre il met en lumière
quoi mais en lumière que malheureusement
le sous-investissement pendant des
décennies sur les 29000 km de réseau de
la SNCF notre patrimoine commun on
conduit à ces interruptions à ses
déficits de matériel et c'est bien cette
inversion que nous envisageons avec ce
coi et ses conclusions
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Alexandra
borschoffonti pour le groupe les
républicains
madame la ministre en France plus de la
moitié des étudiants de première année
de licence échoue dès lors que
pensez-vous de la casse organisée par
parcoursup
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'Enseignement supérieur et
de la Recherche madame Sylvie Retailleau
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les sénatrices madame la
sénatrice c'est une question claire
concise auquel je vais essayer de
répondre aussi clairement dans le temps
qui m'est imparti tout d'abord je
voudrais vous dire que parcoursup c'est
un outil c'est un outil dans lequel nous
sommes et vous êtes probablement très
sollicite en cette période et auquel
nous devons répondre dans son volet
d'orientation et c'est dans lequel nous
travaillons avec le ministre de
l'éducation nationale parce
qu'effectivement la réussite de nos
étudiants liés à la loi du 8 mars 2018
avec des volets d'orientation et la
partie d'orientation donc l'année
prochaine le ministre a décidé de
généraliser l'expérimentation par
exemple de la découverte des métiers au
collège dès la 5ème 3ème en lycée il y a
l'orientation avec les professeurs
principaux en terminale et nous
continuons à travailler bien évidemment
pour donner les ressources nécessaires
pour mieux personnaliser humaniser cette
orientation et permettre aux élèves et
donc au futur étudiants de trouver leur
voie leur voix adaptée à eux pour
pouvoir exercer le métier de leur choix
et puis dans le supérieur il y a la loi
réussite et orientation qui a apporté
effectivement des outils des moyens aux
établissements et je vous rejoins le
premier cycle est un enjeu particulier
pour nos établissements nous les y
accompagnons nous les y accompagnons en
regardant les débouchés l'insertion
professionnelle et dans ce sens nous
avons renseigné parcoursup sur la
transparence non seulement des critères
d'examens des vœux c'est important de
savoir mais aussi sur l'orientation les
taux de réussite les taux d'insertion et
nous avons travaillé tous ensemble pour
améliorer mieux accompagner et rendre ce
côté humain d'orientation
d'accompagnement et de réussite je vous
remercie madame la sénatrice
madame la ministre ma question
s'adressée également bien sûr au
ministre de l'éducation nationale encore
des annonces j'allais dire conjuguer au
futur on s'y attendait évidemment le
président de la République on a fait
autant avant-hier à Marseille depuis 5
ans maintenant les étudiants tentent de
trouver des stratégies pour déjouer le
dispositif les enseignants eux aussi
d'ailleurs essayent de donner les moyens
à leurs élèves d'accéder à leurs projets
inflation inouïe de la notation dans le
bulletin scolaire surenchère des
appréciations des enseignants ou le
dithyramb est devenu la règle certains
lycées pratiquent même le double
bulletin c'est à dire une autre vitrine
pour parcoursup et puis une autre
véritable pour informer quand même
l'élève de son niveau réel quant au
système lui-même complexité technique de
la plateforme lettre de motivation non
examinée ou encore critères de sélection
d'une totale opacité parcoursup à
renverser le bac déjà affaibli par le
contrôle continu dont les notes varient
d'un établissement à l'autre par
l'angoisse de l'arbitraire froid de
l'algorithme on a déshumanisé cette
dernière étape de la vie scolaire au nom
d'un impératif technocratique parcoursup
pas également désorganiser l'année
terminale les élèves ont cinq mois
désormais pour se préparer aux épreuves
une incongruité supplémentaire qui
accentue l'absentéisme lors du dernier
trimestre c'est juste trois mois
d'apprentissage perdu et puis une
épreuve de philo dévalorisée une
régression pédagogique qui aggrave les
inégalités impactent les chances de
réussite d'une jeunesse sacrifiée sur
l'hôtel de parcoursup Madame la Ministre
le 1er juin est devenu la Journée
nationale de l'angoisse Cesson cette
absurdité bureaucratique pour l'accès au
savoir en tout cas nous sénateurs du
groupe les républicains nous demandons
la création d'un véritable service
public de l'orientation dont le but
n'est pas d'avoir 100% de réussite au
bac mais plutôt d'instruire de bien
former et de mieux orienter cette
ambition éducative est aussi humaniste
servons-nous des outils numériques pour
garantir un processus d'orientation et
pour documenter vos travaux je propose
de suivre les recommandations de notre
rapporteur Jacques gros Perrin
merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue de vie de souligne avant de
d'aller plus loin dans la parole je
voudrais le remercier pour ces adénas et
mes chers collègues si vous avez un
écran devant vous et à votre numérique
automatique c'est un avis d'hasouline
que vous le devez dans sa période de
vice-président du Sénat voilà
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président mais chers
collègues monsieur le ministre au moment
de ma dernière mon groupe que je salue
m'a fait l'honneur de me confier une
question qui fut au coeur de mon
engagement de mes plaidoiries de mes
travaux avec vous dans cette émission
depuis de nombreuses années
l'indépendance le plus réalise et la
liberté des médias je veux vous dire
notre inquiétude car au concentration
économique qui monopolise les médias
entre quelques groupes industriels et
financiers dont l'activité principale
est le plus souvent étrangère à la
presse à la formation ou à la culture se
construit devant nous un empire
médiatique de propagande au service
d'une idéologie qui promeut la haine de
l'autre
en effet Monsieur Bolloré qui est en son
empire à la télé à la radio à la presse
écrite au cinéma et à l'édition
qui en contrôle presque la totalité y
compris la majorité des livres scolaires
détruit des rédactions entières comme à
iTélé aura pas Paris Match et maintenant
le JDD on lui imposant contre son avis
exprimé à 98% par les journalistes
indirecteur renvoyé d'un journal
d'extrême droite parce qu'il était
lui-même trop d'extrême droite monsieur
le ministre vous ne pouvez pas nous dire
qu'on ne peut rien faire car la
situation est grave on peut mieux
protéger l'indépendance des rédactions
en leur permettant de valider à une
majorité qualifiée leur directeur
proposé par l'actionnaire et les états
généraux de la formation promis par le
Président de la République c'est pour
quand
on veut répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé du renouveau
démocratique Monsieur Olivier Véran
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur David à souligne à mon tour et
au nom du gouvernement je voudrais
saluer votre action comme sénateur
toutes ces années et l'apport qui aura
été le vôtre dans cette Haute Assemblée
monsieur le sénateur vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur la question du rachat
enfin pas du rachat pardonnez-moi de la
nomination Geoffre le jeune à la tête du
JDD comme vous êtes un très fin
connaisseur des règles dans le milieu
culturel vous savez qu'il ne revient pas
au gouvernement de décider qui va
diriger tel ou tel journal évidemment et
d'ailleurs si c'était le cas ce serait
grave je pense qu'il y aurait uneanimité
sur ces bancs pour considérer que nous
outre passerions nos droits l'État est
là pour garantir le pluralisme et la
liberté de la presse il est là aussi
pour financer plus de 400 titres de
presse ont été subventionnés l'année
dernière et c'est très bien ainsi ils
n'empêche pas qu'il qu'on peut se poser
la question on peut se poser la question
de savoir s'il ne faut pas mettre à
l'abri je dirais des comités de
rédaction de l'influence actionnaire
c'est une question qui est légitime vous
vous soulignez par exemple la
possibilité de soumettre au suffrage des
rédacteurs des journalistes
quotidien ou d'un autre journal le vote
pour désigner le rédacteur en chef je
sais que certains journaux le font comme
par exemple les échos moi j'ai envie de
vous dire Monsieur le Sénateur il va y
avoir d'abord il y a une réflexion qui a
commencé au Parlement sous l'égide de la
ministre de la Culture dont j'excuse
l'absence d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est
avec le président de la République à
Marseille et le parlementaire ont aussi
pour objectif de regarder la loi blanche
de 2016 pour voir ce qui pourrait être
éventuellement renforcé améliorer ou
modifier dans ce cadre-là par ailleurs
vous l'avez dit vous-même le président
de la République souhaite organiser des
états généraux de l'information qui
pourraient être pourquoi pas une
opportunité pour aborder ce type de
problématique il ne me revient pas de
vous dire que c'est précisément ce type
de problématique que nous aborderons
mais dès lors qu'on ouvre ce chantier
qui est important et bien on pourra se
poser toutes les questions qui qui
conviennent donc voilà monsieur le
sénateur j'espère avoir répondu non pas
sur le cas précis qui vous occupe et qui
vous mobilise mais sur le cas général de
l'indépendance du pluralisme et de la
liberté de la presse
je suis
la parole
est à notre collègue Laurent saumon pour
le groupe les républicains
madame la Première ministre Pierre Dac
disait il faut une infinie patience pour
attendre toujours ce qui n'arrive jamais
à l'étude depuis 1990 en état de mort
clinique en 2016 malgré un débat public
qui a conclu à l'excellent rentabilité
socio-économique du dossier réanimer en
mars 2017 et promis par le Premier
ministre Bernard Cazeneuve dans le cadre
du plan de revitalisation de laminoir le
barreau TGV Creil Roissy était
formellement acté par un courrier du
président de la République le 12 août
2019 adressé à Madame le maire d'Amiens
après que vous-même madame la Première
ministre l'ayez annoncé en avril 2019
lors d'une visite dans la capitale
picarde le courrier précisé en outre le
calendrier et sa mise en service en 2025
annoncé à 310 millions et arrivé à 580
millions d'euros aujourd'hui le plan de
financement a été bouclé avec une
participation de 51% de l'État
l'adjonction des collectivités locales
Région Département EPCI et communes le
coût marginal devait être couvert par
une participation de Union européenne à
hauteur de 80 millions d'euros je dis
nous apprenions le rejet de cette
demande présentée à deux reprises à
l'Union européenne je reprendrai donc
les propos du président de l'Association
des maires de France au sujet des
défaillances successives états y es-tu
entends-tu que fais-tu plus précisément
madame la première Mini je vous demande
premièrement peut-on encore avoir
confiance dans la parole du président de
la République de les engagements écrits
des gouvernements sont-ils encore
crédibles et l'État a-t-il le pouvoir de
contraindre la volonté réfractaire de
SNCF réseau pour que soit mis les moyens
engager les travaux et respecter le
calendrier et enfin surtout la France
a-t-elle encore une présence efficace et
une influence réelle au sein de l'Union
européenne et suppléez-vous et
suppléez-vous ces financements manquants
alors pour vous répondre
la parole des communistes transition
écologique la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur saumon il est singulier de
pointer la responsabilité du Président
de la République alors que vous avez
précisément indiqué ce qui était le
point de départ des inquiétudes
légitimes de la somme des
Hauts-de-France de manière générale
après les prises de parole très fortes
en particulier du président Xavier
Bertrand il y a quelques jours le 22
juin la commission attribué au projet
français une note de 19 sur 25 mais qui
ne nous a pas permis d'obtenir de
financement avec un point positif qui
est la reconnaissance européenne du
projet et dans les points négatifs le
fait de constater qu'il y avait un
certain nombre qui devaient être
apportées ce chemin là il dessine la
possibilité pour nous de redéposer une
demande avant le 1er janvier 2024 de
boucler le dossier de financement en
fonction de ça au mois d'octobre et de
pouvoir envisager un démarrage de
travaux en 2024 pour une mise en service
en 2025
Clément Beaune là encore a eu le
président Bertrand au téléphone il a
redit dimanche que non seulement ça ne
modifiait pas le soutien du gouvernement
français à ce projet mais que notre
engagement réalisé ces 6 km et demi dont
vous l'avez dit l'ensemble des
conditions socio-économiques ont y
compris été pointé comme étant favorable
par la Commission européenne renforce
notre détermination dans ce contexte je
considère que ce refus de la Commission
européenne il doit pas nous conduire à
nos diviser entre nous aller chercher
ses crédits européens pour obtenir le
complément du financement c'est la
priorité absolue si d'aventure nous ne
les avions pas on entrerait dans autre
chose mais partir du principe que nous
n'aurions pas cet argent alors que le
projet est reconnu comme étant d'intérêt
européen je pense que ce serait
collectivement nous affaiblir dans un
contexte de négociation ou au contraire
on doit être soudé vous exprimez
l'exaspération le ras-le-bol et la tente
des territoires vous rappelez la date de
2025 je ne fais pas autre chose je vous
demande qu'on monte à bord dans cette
bataille nouvelle devant la Commission
européenne et je vous redis ce projet
nous le ferons
monsieur saumon
monsieur le ministre vous avez
effectivement rappelé les propos du
ministre qui rappelaient dimanche Creil
Roissy est un projet qui avance et se
fera malheureusement on avance à la
vitesse de la draisine on peut craindre
de vivre les propos de Marcel Proust à
savoir qu'on a plus rien à espérer
n'empêche pas de continuer à attendre
alors même en perte de vitesse sur le
réseau européen respectez vos
engagements accélérer pour que la France
retrouve sa locomotive et à la vitesse
du TGV permettait comme la promis le
président de la République que les
trains arrivent en temps et en heure à
sa ville natale
la parole est à notre collègue François
bodot pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Madame la première
midi mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la ministre des Affaires
étrangères
les récents événements impliquant le
groupe islamiste paramilitaire pardon
Wagner ne manqueront pas d'avoir des
conséquences en Afrique le groupe est
présent au Soudan en République
centrafricaine en Libye au Mali et aux
Mozambique
Wagner est devenu un outil important de
la lutte d'influence russe en Afrique
développant un panel d'activités allant
de la protection des États à
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
en passant par les opérations
d'information et surtout de
désinformation à la fois antioxydantal
essentiellement anti-française
cependant la rupture entre Wagner et le
Kremlin a de fortes chances de
déstabiliser les opérations de Wagner en
Afrique de l'Ouest
en tant que paria soumis à la vindique
de ces commanditaires russes Wagner et
son dirigeant Afghani privé pourrait se
retrouver dans une position instable et
délicate
les activités brutales et sanglantes de
Wagner sont largement financés par
l'exploitation illégitime des ressources
naturelles c'est pourquoi les États-Unis
ont annoncé hier de nouvelles sanctions
contre les activités de Wagner visant à
empêcher son expansion en Afrique
dans ce contexte il est crucial que la
France agisse de manière énergique en
intensifiant sa coopération avec nos
partenaires africains notamment dans le
Golfe de Guinée très inquiet à la fois
de la contagion terroriste mais aussi
des milices incontrôlables madame la
ministre quelles conséquence vos
circuits anticipent-ils en Afrique à la
suite de la rupture de banc du groupe
Wagner et comment la France
entend-t-elle réagir pour soutenir nos
partenaires africains et protéger les
intérêts de cette région éminemment
stratégique
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué en charge des Français
de l'étranger du commerce extérieur
monsieur beige
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur François Bonot
d'abord je vous prie d'excuser l'absence
de la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères qui m'a chargé de
vous répondre il faut dire les choses
telles qu'elles sont Wagner ce n'est pas
une société militaire privée ce n'est
pas une milice c'est un groupe criminel
et mafieux qui en a les méthodes la
violence la prédation la manipulation
les règlements de comptes un groupe sur
lequel la Russie s'appuie pour mener les
actions qu'elle n'est pas capable de
conduire avec son armée régulière Wagner
a établi partout où il s'est déployé la
violation systématique des droits de
l'homme en principe cardinal de son
action
celle-ci a systématiquement renforcé la
menace terroriste qu'il prétendait
combattre que ce soit en Syrie en Libye
au Mozambique au Mali ou en République
de Centrafrique Wagner est un véritable
fléau dont le seul objectif est de
piller les richesses au détriment des
États et des populations et au prix
d'exaction atroces j'en veux pour preuve
le rapport accablant des Nations Unies
qui établit clairement la responsabilité
du groupe Wagner dans le massacre de 500
civils à Moura au Mali en mars 2022
nous ne laisserons aucun espace à cette
organisation qui n'hésite pas à recruter
parmi les criminels les plus endurci
dans les prisons russes et pour répondre
concrètement à votre question oui nous
continuerons à imposer des sanctions
européennes rigoureuses pour ces actions
en Ukraine comme en Afrique et nous
disons au pays qui ont fait le choix de
Wagner et qui peut-être d'ailleurs le
regret en voyant les événements de ce
week-end qu'il est temps de s'en
dissocier car rien de bon ne peut sortir
du chaos dont Wagner s'est fait une
spécialité je vous remercie monsieur
Bono
vous avez quelques secondes
oui monsieur ministre effectivement la
Russie poutinienne n'a cessé de
fustiger nos démocratie
occidentales force c'est de constater
que c'est au contraire la dictature
russe qui pourrie de l'Intérieur
agissons fermement pour regagner les
positions que nous avons perdu
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Guillaume
Chevrollier pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'arrête le
ministre de la Fonction publique
l'année passée l'apprentissage a atteint
un niveau record plus de 800 000
contrats signés c'est une bonne nouvelle
cependant ce qui concerne la fonction
publique territoriale beaucoup de nos
communes rurales nous alerte sur leurs
difficultés à recruter les candidats
sont nombreux mais il est financements
ne suivent pas pour l'année 2023 18000
intentions de recrutement des
collectivités ont été recensés alors
même que le budget prévu ne permet d'en
financer que 10 000 en mars dernier la
circulaire relative au renforcement du
recrutement d'apprentis dans la fonction
publique précisait que les objectifs
d'embauche
et annonçaient la baisse progressive de
la participation de France compétences
au frais de formation en apprentissage à
hauteur de 15 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui elle s'élèvera seulement 5
millions d'euros pour 2025 et rien n'est
prévu pour compenser cette diminution
par la suite
les mers et l'ensemble des élus
s'enquête vivement ainsi que les centres
de formation comme les Maisons
Familiales Rurales ce n'est pas la faute
d'avoir alerté le gouvernement à ce
sujet lors des débats sur le projet de
loi de finance pourtant madame la
Première ministre a déclaré à ton un
engagement fort des employeurs publics
espérant dépasser prochainement le
million d'apprentis hors forcer de
constater qu'un décalage subsiste entre
l'ambition affichée et les moyens
alloués à terme ainsi que la complexité
du cadre juridique même le Centre
national de la fonction publique
territoriale insiste régulièrement sur
l'insuffisance des financements par
rapport aux besoins alors monsieur le
ministre le gouvernement compte-t-il
revoir ses objectifs en matière
d'apprentissage et réévaluer les moyens
financiers à la hauteur des besoins des
collectivités locales
pour vous répondre la parole deobilise
la transformation de la fonction
publique sur Guérini
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Chevrolet je veux dire trois
choses pour répondre à votre question la
première c'est un satisfait site
collectif nous avons fait dans la
fonction publique ces dernières années
la révolution de l'apprentissage faut se
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont il
y a quelques années il n'y avait pas
d'apprenti dans la fonction publique et
collectivité hôpitaux administration
concentrée ou déconcentré ça marche nous
avons massivement recruté des apprentis
plus de 30 000 pour l'année 2022
deuxième élément l'État s'est engagé
vous le savez auprès des employeurs
territoriaux et compte maintenir cette
engagement c'est 15 millions d'euros sur
les lignes de mon ministère 15 millions
d'euros de France compétences et ça
marche pour l'année dernière il y avait
un objectif de 8000 apprentis dans la
fonction publique territoriale il a été
largement dépassé alors d'ici quelques
jours nous signerons avec le CNFPT que
vous avez mentionné monsieur le sénateur
une nouvelle convention pour l'exercice
2025 le CNFPT prend des engagements
celui de financer pour les collectivités
au moins 9000 apprentis dans les
exercices qui viennent année après année
et je prends des engagements puisque les
crédits de mon ministère seront
maintenus 45 millions d'euros pour les
trois prochaines années pour nous donner
de la visibilité mais monsieur le
sénateur et c'est la troisième chose que
je voulais vous dire je ne veux pas
m'arrêter là je crois que tous ensemble
nous pouvons faire de l'apprentissage
une vraie voix de pré recrutement pour
la fonction publique comment expliquer
aujourd'hui qu'à l'issue d'un contrat
d'apprentissage parfois 18 mois quand y
compris l'employeur territorial parfois
la collectivité est jeune apprenti
veulent pouvoir embaucher c'est-à-dire
titulariser l'apprenti dans la fonction
publique il faut qu'il puisse repasser
par la case concours passer une année à
préparer un concours administratif nous
perdons aujourd'hui les apprentis je
veux faire en sorte et je vous ferai les
propositions en ce sens dans les
prochains mois que nous puissions lever
cette obligation du concours à la fin
des contrats d'apprentissage et
permettre une titularisation directe je
crois que c'est comme ça moyen l'appui
que nous gagnerons les batailles
d'apprentissage dans la fonction
publique
je suis chevrolier oui merci monsieur
missoui nous croyons à l'apprentissage
mais nécessaire de mieux cibler la
politique en matière d'apprentissage
dans la fonction publique et le
désengagement unilatéral de l'État pour
le financement a pour conséquence de
peser sur les finances des collectivités
locales encore un transfert de charges
qui n'est pas acceptable pour les élus
locaux et qui est dommageable pour les
jeunes en attente de formation merci la
parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Jacquin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des Transports allez vous tenir
vos engagements le 22 mars dernier
auditionné à l'Assemblée nationale Bruno
Le Maire annonçait sais saisir le
Conseil d'État pour étudier la
possibilité de raccourcir les durées des
concessions autoroutières il écartait de
fait les deux autres options mises sur
la table par l'Inspection générale des
finances dans un rapport révélé par Le
Canard enchaîné à savoir la diminution
des prix des péages
le prélèvement sur les bénéfices des
sociétés concessionnaires nous avons
appris la semaine dernière une nouvelle
fois par voie de presse que le Conseil
d'État aurait rendu son avis il
privilégierait une hausse de la
fiscalité sur les concessions que le
ministre de l'Économie considérait en
mars être je cite une impasse compte
tenu du caractère stratégique des
autoroutes tant pour l'aménagement du
territoire que pour la transition
écologique des transports et à moins de
10 ans de la fin des premiers contrats
allez vous publier la saisine et l'avis
du Conseil d'État comme vous étiez
engagé auprès de notre collègue député
socialiste Christine Pirès bone le 3 mai
dernier par ailleurs quand allez-vous
enfin lancer des Assises des autoroutes
que vous nous promettez depuis trois
mois je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur Béchu
le Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Jacquin
compte tenu des textes dont vous êtes
l'auteur des prises de parole à
répétition sur ce sujet je ne suis pas
surpris de vous trouver comme étant
l'auteur de cette question vous pouvez
éventuellement être surpris que je sois
le répondant mais je le redis l'absence
de Clément baume me conduit à remplacer
mon ministre délégué sur ce sujet et à
vous répondre
vous avez parfaitement suivi les
épisodes précédents et dans les épisodes
précédents précisément dans les réponses
qui ont pu être faites dans cette
émission par Bruno Le Maire par Clément
baume dans le cadre des commissions
dédiées nous avons évoqué le fait que
nous étions dans un cadre particulier
qui était celui des concessions avec des
règles juridiques et donc on a joué un
geste à la parole et le Conseil d'État
était saisi de deux questions peut-on
raccourcir unilatéralement une durée de
concession sans être amené à la
compensée de manière intégrale la
réponse est non les raisons qui
permettraient d'aller justifier
l'intérêt général ne peuvent pas tenir à
une appréciation éventuelle d'un niveau
de rentabilité tant que la durée globale
de concession n'est pas terminée parce
qu'on ne peut pas apprécier seulement
sur une partie du temps ce que produit
sur la totalité de la concession le
résultat économique global et si nous le
faisions il faudrait à ce moment-là
qu'on compense financièrement
intégralement à coups de dizaines de
milliards d'euros les années dont on a
pu très le contrat tel qu'il a été signé
la deuxième question c'est peut-on taxer
avec un biais l'IS A B C de 33 à 25% des
calculs de rentabilité c'était établies
sur une base éventuelle qui était celle
du niveau de fiscalité existante le
Conseil d'État dit quoi il dit un c'est
possible mais vous devez considérer les
concessions comme une catégorie homogène
vous ne pouvez pas considérer qu'il y
aurait d'un côté les concessions
d'autoroute et de l'autre d'autres
formes de concession nationale qui
échapperait à la même approche d'une
évolution de la fiscalité sur la durée
qui modifierait les conditions initiales
qui avaient été imaginées sous cette
réserve d'homogénéité des dispositifs
fiscaux sont possibles vous savez que
nous travaillons au financement de la
transition écologique que le financement
de cette transition écologique et en
particulier le plan qui concerne les
transports passent par le fait que nous
puissions verdir ou aller chercher des
dépenses brunes pour faire en sorte
c'est ce à quoi nous sommes précisément
en train de travailler
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
des collectivités pour la précision de
votre réponse dans ce domaine mais vous
assumez d'être favorable aux concessions
et défendez un modèle déséquilibré vous
obligeant à quémander des risques
tournes pour les usagers spolier comme
le dernier sketch des chats vacances
l'état régulateur doit reprendre la main
et préparer véritablement la précession
écrire et lancer de nouveaux contrats
ces 5 ans de travail le Sénat vous le
répète depuis 2020 d'autres modèles
existent avec notre groupe nous avons
proposé la création d'un épique route de
France qui gèrerait l'ensemble du réseau
routier national alors débattons-en
enfin c'est l'intérêt des Français des
entreprises des territoires et du climat
je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue
Jean-Claude Angleur pour le groupe les
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 8 novembre 2022 le président
de la République présentant le plan
France 2030 déclarait son ambition de
faire de la France le leader de
l'hydrogène des carbonées est fixait
l'objectif d'un renforcement de la
stratégie nationale hydrogène sous 6
mois 6 mois plus tard nous y sommes le
23 juin c'est la direction de Bosch
Allemagne qui s'exprime et annonce sa
décision de suspendre le projet fresh
tout d'ici la fin de l'année et pour
plusieurs années jusqu'à ce que le
marché de l'hydrogène soit établi
durablement le projet fresh tout vise à
développer la pile combustible à
hydrogène destinée à remplacer le moteur
diesel utilisé dans le transport c'est
le projet de reconversion industrielle
du site Bosch donner le château
usine historique de fabrication des
injecteurs et bougies de moteur diesel
condamnés en 2020 par l'abandon
précipité du diesel
la déclaration de l'industriel est un
coût de tonnerre dans le ciel aveyronné
ce choix sans explication et sans
informations préalables apparaît comme
une remise en cause des engagements pris
auprès des syndicats des élus locaux et
de l'état car l'équipementier s'est
engagé à maintenir 250 emplois
reconvertis sur les technologies
hydrogènes en 2028 en contrepartie de la
transformation industrielle l'annonce de
Bosch est une condamnation des 250
derniers emplois or monsieur le ministre
depuis cette annonce la semaine dernière
vous n'avez fait aucune déclaration
alors que la stratégie nationale
d'hydrogène que vous défendez vise à
développer les véhicules lourds propres
et construire en France une filière
industrielle créatrice de 50 à 150 000
emplois que fait le gouvernement pour le
développement du projet de reconversion
de l'usu d'une Bosch donner le château
que faites-vous pour les 250 emplois
aveyronnés à convertir et pérenniser
on vous répond la parole est au ministre
délégués en charge de l'Industrie
monsieur Lescure
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur merci pour votre question qui
me permet du coup de m'exprimer
officiellement et publiquement sur ce
sujet vous le savez la sortie programmée
du véhicule thermique est un vent de
face extrêmement important pour
l'industrie automobile traditionnelle et
nous avons le temps c'est d'ici 2035
mais nous devons adapter l'appareil de
production à ce nouveau défi Bosch est
un grand groupe européen très présent en
France plus de 6000 emplois à ce stade
dont 1200 en Aveyron à Rodez
la décision prise par le groupe bouche
annoncé à gauche pardon annoncé la
semaine dernière nous indiquant que le
projet de diversification sur
l'hydrogène que vous avez très bien
écrit n'était plus suffisamment rentable
à court terme pour l'envisager d'ici
2028 ne doit en aucun cas je vais être
très clair changer en quoi que ce soit
les engagements du Groupe Bosch pris
dans le cas d'un accord courageux de la
part des salariés avec les organisations
syndicales en décembre 2021 j'ai échangé
avec tous les élus aujourd'hui avec vous
hier avec les députés à l'Assemblée
nationale avec madame la présidente de
région monsieur le Président du
département et Monsieur le Maire de
Rodez nous sommes tous alignés nous
devons nous assurer que Bosch tiendra
ces engagements mon équipe est déjà en
relation avec les organisations
syndicales mais aussi la direction
France de Bosch mais vous le savez cette
décision elle sera prise en Allemagne
j'ai déjà appris contact avec la
direction allemande avec laquelle je
vais échanger de manière formelle dans
les jours qui viennent mon message sera
clair les engagements doivent être tenus
hydrogène ou autre chose la Reval la
revitalisation du site et le maintien de
250 emplois vous l'avez mentionné dans
l'hydrogène mais d'autres sont de plus
l'emploi total c'était 500 on est
aujourd'hui à 1200 on doit s'assurer
qu'en 2028 500 employés travaillant sur
ce site que ce soit l'hydrogène ou autre
chose je m'y engage devant vous et
évidemment
j'informerai tous les élus du
département de la région de l'avancée de
ces discussions merci sur glace
quelques secondes
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
réponses mais j'allais vous inviter à
venir en Aveyron avec votre collègue
monsieur Dupont-Moretti qui vient
vendredi pour expliquer cela à tous les
élus et tous les syndicats etc n'avons
voilà merci
la parole est notre collègue Olivier
Hinault pour le groupe de l'Union
européenne
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question concerne la récente
expulsion de Monsieur Saya dont l'arrêté
date du 26 octobre dernier ce citoyen
algérien était connu comme président de
la mosquée Asuna à Hautmont dans
laquelle je cite l'arrêter il dit il
dispensait un islam salafiste et
notamment des prêches marquées par des
propos légitimement le jihad armé
appelant à la violence à la haine à la
discrimination et à la commission
d'actes de terrorisme excusé du peu que
cette personne en rupture avec les
valeurs de la République soient
retournés en Algérie tant mieux c'est le
résultat de la volonté de l'État et je
salue la prise de position de ce jour
dans la presse du préfet de région mais
aussi et surtout du courage et de la
pertinence des choix du maire d'Aumont
Stéphane villemotte et je veux saluer
son courage son courage d'avoir refusé
le mariage de cette personne qui aurait
sans doute empêché son expulsion or pour
avoir dénoncé cette instrumentalisation
du mariage par cet individu
le maire d'Aumont c'est trouvé sous le
feu de menace d'insultes et
d'intimidation fallait-il à ce propos
laisser s'organiser ce dimanche la
manifestation de soutien à Monsieur Saya
qui n'avait pas d'autres objets que de
faire psychologiquement pression sur le
maire d'Aumont or c'est bien ce dont il
s'agit une forme de violence
psychologique dont sont de plus en plus
souvent victimes les élus les violences
physiques aux élus sont intolérables
mais les violents se psychologiques le
sont tout autant elles sont moins
visibles mais plus sournoises plus
fréquente et tout autant grave et
insupportable alors Monsieur le Ministre
ma question est limpide comment
voyez-vous l'accompagnement de l'État
quand les mers sont confrontés à
l'évidence à des mariages de
complaisance ou pire à des mariages
forcés et parfois à une forme de
violence psychologique pour les
prononcer contre leur Grais je vous
remercie
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'Intérieur que Gérald Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Olivier Hainaut merci d'avoir
souligné l'action de l'État sur
l'expulsion de monsieur saillia qui en
effet depuis trop longtemps dans le
Territoire du Nord où vous êtes élu
prenez un islam salafiste était en lien
avec une mosquée qui en effet faisait
l'apologie du terrorisme et après
beaucoup de démarches administratives
comme d'autres va faire plus médiatique
que nous avons connu récemment a pu être
expulsé en effet du territoire national
je voudrais moi aussi remercier le
travail très courageux du maire de
Monsieur Stéphane villemotte parce que
c'est son action avec le préfet de
département des services de
renseignement qu'on a réussi à rétablir
leur public et une certaine idée que
nous avons de la France et de la
pratique religieuse dans notre pays
Monsieur le Maire a été menacé il a été
reçu vous le savez voilà 48 heures par
Monsieur préfet de département qui en
effet à dans La Voix du Nord aujourd'hui
réitérer son soutien j'ai demandé au
préfet du Nord d'interdire la prochaine
manifestation
j'ai demandé au préfet du Nord de se
saisir de la loi séparative ce que vous
avez voté et qui permet de créer un
délit justement de pression contre le
service public et notamment les élus et
qu'il saisisse par article 40 procureur
de la République pour pouvoir poursuivre
évidemment ceux qui font des pressions
plus ou moins directes contre Monsieur
le Maire et son conseil municipal je
veux d'ailleurs dire que les policiers
qui ont procédé parfois aux
interventions ont vu leur nom publier et
que je souhaite également que le préfet
puisse poursuivre enfin poursuivre par
le procureur de la République ces
pressions inacceptables je veux dire que
procédant des mariages sous l'autorité
monsieur le garder ça parce que comme
vous le savez quand le maire Marie il le
fait en lien avec le procureur de la
République nous y travaillons avec
monsieur le garde des sceau pour que les
enquêtes de moralité lorsque les mers
considèrent qu'un mariage n'est pas un
mariage qu'on pourrait évoquer comme
étant un mariage d'amour hommage
librement consenti alors que nous
puissions aider les maires à prendre les
mesures de refus je vais d'ailleurs dire
que ceux qui ont un qtf et qui peuvent
se marier depuis la loi ne permettent
pas de rester sur le territoire national
et personne quand même expulsables et
c'est une très bonne chose et je veux
surtout dire que dedans les moyens avec
Christophe bechy locaux avec
Eric Dupont-Moretti de protéger les mers
c'est le cas monsieur homo qui vous le
savez depuis une sorte depuis quelques
jours et par ces grands protégés par les
forces du ministères de l'Intérieur
la parole est très collect Jean-Louis
Masson pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs ne figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe vous avez la parole
en raison de l'incohérence du
recensement des logements assurés
assujettis à la taxe d'habitation plus
de 40 % des contribuables n'ont pas
répondu c'est le cas de plusieurs
millions de foyers qui continuent à
effectuer leur déclaration de revenus
sur papier et qui n'ont même pas été
informés de ce fait les services fiscaux
viennent de leur adresser une circulaire
leur demandant de se renseigner auprès
des services fiscaux ou de téléphoner à
un numéro national en 08 pour connaître
la procédure à suivre or cette
circulaire est une totale mauvaise foi
car des files d'attente de plusieurs
heures ont été constatées pour l'accès
physique au service fiscaux et lorsqu'on
compose même 20 fois de suite le numéro
national en 08 il est toujours
occupé selon les syndicats en une seule
journée plus de 94.000 personnes ont été
victimes de cette incurie en outre plus
de 20 000 courriers sont par exemple en
attente de réponse dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône et plus dans les
Hautes-Pyrénées il est totalement
inacceptable une fois qu'une fois de
plus les responsables du ministère des
Finances marginalise ceux qui n'ont pas
accès aux numériques je vous demande
donc monsieur le ministre pourquoi le
formulaire papier pré-rempli n'a pas été
adressé par la poste au contribuable
concernés comme c'est le cas pour toutes
les déclarations d'impôt sur le revenu
lorsque les gens ne sont pas branchés
sur internet en outre plusieurs
directeurs départementaux ayant dit que
pour 2023 il n'y aurait pas de pénalité
financière en cas de non-réponse je vous
demande de confirmer cette annonce et
j'insiste sur ce point en souhaitant que
vous ne me répondiez par oui ou par non
et pas par une réponse à moitié
fileteuse ou on ne comprend rien
quand vos réponses la parole est au
ministre déléguée en charge des comptes
publics
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur au moment de la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation a été décidé on
remonte donc à 2019 pour la décision de
mettre en place une déclaration
d'occupation elle est importante pour
les communes puisque les communes
continuent à recevoir une taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires et d'ailleurs le Parlement a
décidé d'élargir la liste des communes
qui peuvent majorer de 60% la taxe
d'habitation sur les résidences
secondaires si on veut qu'elle puisse
recevoir les justes recettes auxquelles
elles ont droit il faut que nous soyons
en capacité de savoir précisément quels
sont les résidences secondaires on ne
veut pas que des contribuables se fasse
taxer sur leur résidence principale une
taxe d'habitation résidence secondaire
ou que des résidences secondaires
échappent à la taxe d'habitation liée
aux résidences secondaires je pense que
les communes seraient les premières à
s'en plaindre d'où le choix à l'époque
en 2019 de mettre en place cette
déclaration d'occupation effectivement
ça entraîné un certain nombre de
difficultés pour des contribuables pas
nécessairement sur le fait qu'il faut
déclarer son bien et son occupation mais
sur les données cadastrales que tout le
monde n'a pas l'habitude de manipuler
même si pour le délai qui était fixé à
la fin du mois de juin c'est seulement
la déclaration d'occupation du logement
et l'identité de la personne qui est
locataire si c'est le cas qui était
nécessaire raison pour laquelle on a
décidé un certain nombre de choses et
notamment de décaler d'un mois le délai
donc vous voyez bien ça répond à votre
deuxième question que notre objectif ça
n'est pas d'aller entre guillemets
pénaliser les contribuables de bonne foi
ça n'est pas l'objet au contraire ce
qu'on veut c'est accompagner et à ce
titre je veux saluer les agents des
finances publiques qui répondent à des
centaines de milliers d'appels qui ont
rempli au lieu et place des
contribuables plusieurs centaines de
milliers de déclarations qui continuent
à travailler il y a eu effectivement un
pic d'appel au moment où la fameuse
circulaire que vous avez évoquée a été
diffusée mais on constate 40% d'appel en
moins depuis la semaine dernière et des
files d'attentes qui se réduisent mais
si on a donné un délai supplémentaire
monsieur le sénateur c'est justement
pour pouvoir accompagner les
contribuables et que personne ne soit
pénalisé je vous le dis c'est cette
ligne de conduite qui continuera à nous
guider encore une fois pour une réforme
et une déclaration qui doit se faire au
bénéfice des communes et des seules
communes pour qu'elles reçoivent les
recettes auxquelles elles ont droit
mes messieurs monsieur le ministre vous
vous moquez du monde je voulais pas
répondu à ma question je vous ai demandé
pourquoi on n'a pas envoyé à tous ceux
par papier la demande et vous avez
absolument pas répondu je vous ai
demandé si c'était vrai que il y aurait
pas de pénalité financière je vous
demandais de répondre par oui ou par non
vous avez pas répondu alors si on te
vous moquez du Parlement monsieur le
ministre
mais
nous en avons terminé avec des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement pour cette
session ordinaire mes chers collègues
mais nous aurons le plaisir de nous
retrouver dans le cadre de la session
extraordinaire le mercredi 5 juin à 15
heures
juillet
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à
16h35 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi relatif à la programmation
militaire la séance est suspendue